dna
just mechanism of storing information
rna dna yeah how big of an invention was
that that seems to be you that seems to
be fundamental to
like something
deep within what life is is the ability
as you said to kind of store and
propagate information but then you also
kind of inferred that with your and your
students work that
there's a deep connection between the
chemistry and the ability
uh to have this kind of genetic
information so how big of an invention
is is it to have
a nice representation a nice hard drive
for info to pass on huge i suspect uh i
mean but
when i was talking about the code you
see the code in rna as well an rna
almost certainly came first
um and there's been an idea going back
decades called the rna world because rna
in theory can
copy itself and can catalyze reactions
so it kind of cuts out this chicken and
egg loop
so dna it's possible it's not that
special so our rna rna is the thing that
does the work really
and the code lies in rna the code lies
in the interactions between rna and
amino acids and it still is there today
in the ribosome for example which is
just kind of a giant ribozyme which is
to say it's an enzyme that's made of rna
um
so
getting to rna i suspect is probably not
that hard
but getting from rna
how do you you know there's multiple
different types of rna now how do how do
how do you distinguish this is something
we're actively thinking how do you
distinguish between you know a random
population of rnas some of them go on to
become
messenger rna this is the the transcript
of the code of the gene that you you
want to make some of them become
transfer rna which is which is the kind
of the unit that holds the amino acid
that's going to be polar polymerized
some of them become uh ribosomal rna
which is the machine which is joining
them all up together
how do they
discriminate themselves and
you know there's some kind of phase
transition going on there what's i don't
know it's a difficult question
and we're now
in the region of biology where
information is coming in but the thing
about rna is very very good at what it
does but the largest genome supported by
rna of rna viruses like hiv for example
they're pretty small
and and so there's a limit to how
complex life could be
unless you come up with dna which
chemically is a really small change but
how easy it is to make that change
i don't really know as soon as you've
got dna then you've got an amazingly
stable molecule for information storage
and you can do absolutely anything but
how likely that transition from rna to
dna was i don't know either how much
possibility is there for variety
in ways to store information because it
seems to be very there's specific
characteristics about
the the programming language of dna yeah
there's a lot of work going on on what's
called xenodna or
rna can we replace the the bases
themselves the the letters if you like
in in in rna or dna can we replace the
backbone can we replace for example
phosphate with arsenate
can we replace the sugar ribose or
deoxyribose with a different sugar and
the answer is yes you can
within limits
there's not an infinite space there
arsenate doesn't really work if the
bonds are not as strong as phosphate
it's probably quite hard to replace
phosphate um
it's possible to do it the question to
me is
why is it this way
is it because there was some form of
selection that this is better than the
other forms and there were lots of
competing forms of information storage
early on and this one was the one that
worked out or was it kind of channeled
that way that these are the molecules
that you're dealing with um and and they
work uh and i'm increasingly thinking
it's that way that we're channeled
towards ribose phosphate and and and the
bases that are used but there are you
know 200 different letters kicking
around out there that could have been
used it's such an interesting question
if you look at in the programming world
in computer science there's a
programming language called javascript
yeah which was uh written super quickly
it's a giant mess but it took over the
world
and it was sounds very biological
it was it was kind of a running joke
that like um
like surely this can't be
the it's a terrible programming language
it's a giant mess it's full of bugs it's
so easy to write really crappy code but
it took over all
a front-end development in the web
browser
if you have any kind of dynamic
interactive website it has it's usually
running javascript
and it's now taking over much of the
back end which is like the serious heavy
duty computational stuff and it's become
super fast with the different
compilation engines um that are running
it so it's like it really took over the
world it's very possible that this
initially crappy
uh derided language actually takes
everything over and then the question is
did human civilization always strive
towards javascript
or was javascript just the first
programming language that ran on the
browser and still sticky the first
the first is the sticky one and so it
wins over anything else because it was
first and then we i don't think that's
answerable right but it's good to
ask that i suppose in the lab uh you
can't
you can't um
run it with programming languages but in
biology you can probably
do some kind of
um
small scale evolutionary
test to try to infer which which is
which yeah i mean in a way we've got the
hardware and the software here and the
the the hardware is maybe the the dna
and the rna itself and then the software
perhaps is more about the code
is did the code have to be this way
could it have been a different way yeah
people talk about the optimization of
the code and there's some suggestion for
that uh i think it's weak actually
but you could imagine you could come out
with a million different codes and and
this would be one of the best ones
um
well we don't know this
well i mean people have tried to model
it based on the effect that mutations
would have
um so no you're right we don't know
because that's the thing that's a single
assumption that a mutation is is what's
being selected on there and there's
other possibilities too i mean there
does seem to be a resilience and a
redundancy to the whole thing it's hard
to mess up
in in the way you mess it up
often
is likely to produce interesting results
so it's um are you talking about
javascript or the genetic code now
yeah well i mean it's almost you know
biology is underpinned by this kind of
mess as well you look at the human
genome and it's full of
stuff that is really either broken or
dysfunctional or was a virus once or
whatever it may be and somehow it works
and maybe we need a lot of this mess you
know we know that some functional genes
are taken from this mess
you